Alright,
so
postmoderns and we talked about it a
little bit,
we'll return to it.
Now we're going to talk a little bit
about Marxism.
I've got a quote here from mark's.
The proletarians have nothing to lose,
but they're chains.
Uh,
well,
that was pretty good for like 1880 or
1890 or whenever it was.
He wrote it.
Somewhere around that period of time it
turned out the proletarians had a lot
more to lose than their chains.
They had their lives and their families
to lose.
That was demonstrated and play as a
consequence of the,
what would you call it,
the sociological movements that were put
into place when the Marxist
presuppositions began to govern
societies like the Soviet Union.
So,
all right,
so let's take the same postmodernist
approach.
So here's some basic tenants of Marxism.
It's Berge Lousy against proletariat and
the bourgeoisie year.
They're capitalists,
the property owners,
those sorts of people.
The proletariat,
the working class,
for all intents and purposes.
The basic idea is that history itself is
nothing but the,
what would you call it?
The documentation of the struggle of one
class against the other.
Okay.
No,
like,
that's wrong,
but it's okay because it's too simple.
Obviously.
It's obviously too simple.
There's all sorts of motivations that
people have.
Some of them are economic,
some of them are associated with power.
Um,
but that's okay.
We will leave that.
Let's,
let's give the devil his due and say,
well,
yeah,
fair enough.
There is still a fair bit of tension
between the haves and the haves and the
have nots.
And maybe that was even more intense and
previous societies than it is now.
And it's no,
there's no doubt that economics plays a
role in,
in virtually everything that human
beings do in a fairly significant role.
So let,
let's,
let's accept that as a potential theory.
It's,
it's simple,
but maybe it's practically useful.
And then there's kind of an offshoot of
that theory,
which is that,
well,
if you're a Marxist,
that means you have sympathy for the
working class.
Right?
Because that's what you're saying all
the time.
It's like,
well,
the poor working class,
they're all oppressed.
The poor,
poor proletariat,
you know.
And then you're also saying,
well,
we're the good guys because we're
standing on the side of the oppressed.
And so then you might also ask what
you're marginalizing when you claim that
you're the good guys because one of the
things that you would be marginalizing
is all of the ways in which you're not
the good guys,
but we can leave that aside for a moment
to.
So there's the claims is that,
you know,
there's the working class against the
ruling class.
Another claim is the ruling class is the
ruined class because they exploit the
working class basically stealing their
excess labor from them.
Um,
another very,
very,
uh,
what,
surfacely attractive claim that lacks
any reasonable justification,
you know,
because it's predicated the idea of the
world as a zero sum game.
And clearly the world is not a zero sum
game.
So when someone creates wealth,
when someone is wealthy,
it can be at least at times because they
created it,
not because they swiped it from someone
else.
I think,
you know,
you can think of someone like Bill Gates
or Steve Jobs is a good example of that.
Um,
you know,
they're,
they're what they produced pad and value
that far exceeded what they garnered as
a consequence of their production even
though what they garnered was fairly
substantial.
So anyways,
but we'll get,
like you said,
we're going to give the devil his due.
Okay.
It's the bourgeoisie against the
proletariat will accept that.
It's class warfare is the primary
historical mover.
No problem.
Now,
but here's what I'm not willing to give
away so easily.
Uh,
we have sympathy for the working class
primarily,
and we're good because of that.
No,
I'm not gonna just give that away.
So simply.
So let's investigate that a little bit.
Let's see if we can actually figure it
out.
If that's true.
We'll say a use a pragmatic approach
because I'm a pragmatist.
I'm in the William James Sense.
Ah,
uh,
or maybe you can think about it even
more deeply in anciently.
Uh,
there's a statement in the New
Testament,
I think it's by their fruits,
you shall know the fine.